le verdict est tombé dans la sphère
lafarge annulations des poursuites pour
complicité de crimes contre l'humanité
invalidée par la cour de cassation le
cimentier a français est accusé par
plusieurs ex salariés et différentes ong
d'avoir versé plusieurs millions d'euros
à différents groupes terroristes en
syrie dont des ch en 2013 et 2014
les détails avec david khalifa depuis
l'île de la cité à paris un nouveau
rebondissement de taille dans cette
affaire concernant le cimentier français
lafarge puisque la cour de cassation a
invalidé la décision rendue par la cour
d'appel de paris en septembre 2019 qui
avait annulé sa mise en examen pour
complicité de crimes contre l'humanité
une petite victoire donc pour les ong à
l'origine de cette demande par ailleurs
la cour de cassation a également cassé
la décision de la cour d'appel
maintenant la mise en examen du
cimentier pour mise en danger de la vie
est deux truies est la chambre de
l'instruction devra donc se pencher à
nouveau sur ces deux questions la mise
en examen pour financement d'une
entreprise terroriste est également
confirmé le risque d'une condamnation
pour le cimentier français donc plus que
probable plus que possible est ce qui
pourrait créer un véritable scandale
d'état pour rappel l'entreprise de btp
est soupçonné d'avoir versé en 2013 et
à près de 13 millions d'euros à des
groupes terroristes dont dahesh mais
aussi à des intermédiaires comme l'a
précisé l avocat général le cimentier
français ne pouvait pas ignorer le
caractère terroriste de ces
organisations bénéficiaires de ces
versements à savoir que le compte rendu
de la décision de ce dossier n'a pas
deux nuls et à une audience - prononcez
public par la cour de cassation la
décision a simplement été un rendu
disponible sur le site de la cour
priorité au procès du siècle procès a dû
être 13 novembre qui débutera dès demain